so this is Everest base camp at just
about 17,500 feet and it's certainly not
primitive it's going to be our home for
the next few months and there's been a
staff of about 15 Sherpas who have
gotten it ready for us over the last
three weeks and each climbing member has
their own private personal tent so we
can spread out all of our gear and get
ready to go up on each day's climb and
then we also have a nice big dining tent
so the guys are down there cooking away
in the kitchen that they quarried out of
stone whoo
amazing they're down there with the
propane stoves cooking away cooking up a
storm and then they bring it up to our
dining tent and that's where yeah sure
we do our eating and we also have our
teams in there to plan out the climbing
for the next day and they actually then
have another separate tent where they
cook their own personal food for eating
in addition to that we have a
communications tent which will set up
our base station so that we can use
radios from higher on the mountain to
communicate down to base camp a lot of
thought has gone in as to how exactly to
set up our base camp and where to put
the dining tent and our toilet tents and
our shower tents and then also where
we're actually going to get our water
from this is where all of our water is
coming from and it's down inside of but
it's a bit laborious trying to get water
you can see from a small hole up this
hill into our dining tent where it'll be
boiled and treated and all things
considered it's pretty nice it's a
little different from historical base
camp which was just a tent and a stove
to boil some water and often that tent
was shared and now we have a pretty nice
accommodations for the next few months